chaque jour l'agence pour les économies
d'énergie publie une carte de France
pour donner ses conseils en matière de
chauffage c'est ainsi que pour demain
dans les parties rouges ou sombres on
vous dit que le chauffage est possible
en dessous de 15 degrés de température
ambiante dans la zone claire on
déconseille le chauffage ceci je le
répète représente un conseil seulement
un conseil pour les particuliers en
revanche pour les administrations et les
services publics qui avaient le droit de
chauffer seulement depuis aujourd'hui il
y a obligation de ne pas dépasser 19
degrés alors qu'en est-il dans les faits
hier on grelotait avec 13 degrés au
ministère de l'Industrie paraît-il c'est
à dire au ministère de l'Énergie et bien
aujourd'hui nous avons accompagné un
releveur officiel de température
15h30 au ministère de l'Industrie
18,6 degrés Celsius
le releveur un ingénieur du service des
instruments de mesure pour le ministère
de l'Industrie rien à dire
quelle est la température dans cette
salle de mairie
et surmonter en mètre
20,2 degrés Celsius
ce n'est pas conforme à la législation
monsieur
effectivement mais c'est extrêmement
difficile dans un bâtiment ancien comme
celui-ci d'avoir une température
constante dans l'ensemble des pièces et
en plus nous avons ouvert le chauffage
aujourd'hui donc nous sommes encore en
période d'adaptation et de réglages
la température du bureau du courrier
l'Hôtel Matignon et de 21,5 degrés
Celsius dans le bureau du chef du
cabinet du secrétaire général du
gouvernement il y a 18,9 degrés Celsius
tout juste la moyenne pour les services
de Raymond Barre la palme de l'économie
d'énergie revenait cet après-midi à
l'Elysée 16 degré 8 relevés chez les
proches collaborateurs du président
c'était aujourd'hui le premier jour ce
type de contrôle inopiné sera multipliée
ces prochains jours
[Musique]